Alyssa Milano believes all women except
for the women accusing her friends of
sexual assault we will examine how the
me2 movement died yesterday and what
lessons we can learn from its demise on
everything from politics to the
coronavirus then more good news out of
New York more bad news out of the fake
news media and a Bernie bro endorsement
for president Trump all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show so much to get to
today and I want to take a quick moment
to give a shout out to all of our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible you know right now a lot
of uncertainty out there in the economy
and so some sponsors have had a hard
time I want to thank all of the sponsors
who have continued to support us through
this very difficult time for our country
and for the world and for keeping this
show going because what would I do if
this show weren't going anymore I'd have
to sit all alone in quarantine and that
would be no fun at all so I just want to
thank them all very very much we're all
trying to get through this together you
me and last but not least perhaps most
important of all my shows advertising
partners I want to thank our friends
over at legacy bucks
I love legacy bikes actually now is a
great time to go check it out legacy box
what is very simple it's a simple
mail-in service to have all of your home
movies and pictures digitally preserved
on a thumb drive DVD or the cloud it's
extremely easy you just pack it up and
send it over and there's service right
now is on sale for 15% off I love it
maybe you find yourself with a little
more time on your hands these days and
you're looking through old pictures this
is especially great what I used it for
is family members who are no longer with
us I've got these photos I don't have
any digital photos so I got all these
photos there's a lifetime of memories
but if anything happened to these if
there were a fire god forbid or
something like that they'd all be gone
in a flash you just put them in the in
the box you mail them in they make them
digital you can get it on a thumb drive
and get it on the cloud it's just
fabulous to brighten your day legacy box
is currently offering oh forget 15% an
incredible 50% off
prices start at just $34.99 buy today to
take advantage of this exclusive offer
send in when you're ready Wow oh man
that's better than 15 that's 50 get
started preserving your past today
legacy box.com slash anoles KO wles
save 50% while supplies last by today to
take advantage of this exclusive offer
send in when you're ready go to legacy
box.com slash Knowles and save 50% while
supplies last
alright mark it on your calendars mark
it for the history books
April 6th 2020 at 10:57 a.m. was the
precise moment the me to movement died
that was the time and the death of the
me to movement has important lessons for
everything from politics to coronavirus
how did it die it died because Alyssa
Milano took the me to have meant to me
to movement out back like Old Yeller and
shot it in the head she ended it without
any question she did that because of Joe
Biden you might remember a few weeks ago
we talked about this on the show there's
a woman who's come out to accuse Joe
Biden of sexually assaulting her her
name is Tara Reid not the actress
different Tara Reid here is her story so
remember that kind of stuff I remember
like I was wearing a blouse and he just
had me up against the wall and the wall
was cold and I remember he it happened
all at once
the gym bag I don't know where it when I
handed it to him was gone and then his
hands were on me and underneath my
clothes and yeah and then he went um he
went down my skirt but then up inside it
and he kind of traded me with those
singers and um I he was kissing me at
the same time and he was saying
something to me he said several things
that I can't remember everything he said
I remember a couple of things I remember
him saying first like as he was doing it
do you want to go somewhere else
and then him saying to me when I pulled
away he got finished doing what he was
doing and I I was pulled back and he
said he said come on man
I heard you liked me this is a pretty
serious allegation this is a lot more
than just hair sniffing now for the
record I don't believe this story I
don't think the story checks out I think
a lot of time has passed
I think her story has changed over the
years I don't think it's credible that's
fine to weigh the evidence and think
it's either false or true that's not
hypocritical if your standard of Justice
is the evidence and weighing the
evidence and trying to come to the truth
that's not hypocritical to hold that
standard of justice it is however
hypocritical for the me2 movement leader
Alyssa Milano Alyssa Milano in
particular Alyssa Milano standard of
Justice is believe all women but Alyssa
Milano
it would seem doesn't believe that woman
but that woman is still a woman so by
Alyssa Milano standard of Justice she's
got to believe her and yet she doesn't
it's pretty awkward why doesn't Alyssa
Milano believe her because she's just
endorsed Joe Biden so what does she
think of this until now she hasn't said
anything she's been completely silent on
the allegation as has the entire
mainstream media because they don't want
to deal with it now Alyssa Milano is in
this impossible situation because the
believe all women premise is absurd
right it the believable women premise is
that women cannot lie that men can lie
but women cannot lie but men and women
are exactly the same and there's no
difference in gender but still women are
protected by the supernatural force
field that forces them to tell the truth
at all times nobody believes that
however it was politically useful to
advance that line when Alyssa Milano
tried to torpedo Brett Cavanaugh's
career and Brett Kavanaugh was
nomination to the Supreme Court without
any evidence
so now Alyssa Milano is finally gonna
speak out on this issue and she's
defending Joe Biden she does not believe
Biden's accuser hears her reasoning I
endorsed Joe Biden okay go ahead there
have been accusations against Joe
about sexual sexual assault
right and people were saying how can you
do that because i was i have not
publicly said anything about this if you
remember it kind of took me a long time
to publicly say anything about about
harvey as well because i believe that um
even though we should believe women and
that is an important thing and what that
statement really means is like you know
for so long the the go to has been not
to believe them so really we have to
sort of societally change that mindset
to believing women now why do i think
there's a but that's about to follow our
state you look we yeah we have to
believe all women and i think we should
totally believe all women like women all
of them
totally got to believe them but but that
does not mean at the expense of not you
know giving men their due process and
and investigate situations right and and
giving you know it it's got to be it's
got to be it's got to be fair and in
both direction oh okay that's what that
means because silly me before i thought
believe all women meant that we had to
believe all women and deny men their due
process rights just like alyssa milano
did to Brett Kavanaugh very famously but
actually now what I'm learning from
Alyssa Milano is that believe all women
means in reality believes some women
when it's politically advantageous and
then disbelieve other women when it's
politically advantageous that's what
that really means it means we need to
get rid of due process rights when
Republicans are being accused of crimes
no matter how frivolous
but we need to defend due process when
Democrats are being accused of crimes
which by the way we already knew because
these feminists harpies never said a
peep when wanita Broderick rather
credibly accused Bill Clinton of rape
decades ago that's how we know
that's how we know that that's what this
always meant Alyssa Milano actually
tweeted out about it she goes quote
there is something to the idea that
people are going to weaponize me - for
political gain she you don't say you
think people would weaponize me - like
Alyssa Milano who sat scowling at Brett
Kavanaugh at his confirmation hearing
holding a sign that said I believe
survivors you mean like that she goes on
just look at the replies here and look
to see whose accounts who those accounts
are supporting in the primary there
always needs to be a thorough vetting of
accusations it's the fact that she can
say this with a straight face is what's
so shocking about it
Alyssa Milano sitting there holding the
sign I believe survivors except she
doesn't believe survivors she
self-identified survivors I suppose I
should say she believes the women that
it's convenient to believe and she
doesn't believe the women that it's not
convenient to believe and this is the
worst standard of justice imaginable
because for instance I don't like Joe
Biden okay I don't think Joe Biden
should be President I don't think he's a
particularly admirable guy it would be
politically advantageous for me and for
other conservatives and Republicans to
believe that this accusation against him
is true but I don't I don't believe it's
true
I think her story has changed I think
it's very convenient now that she's
attacking him all these years later I we
don't see any other evidence of this and
Joe Biden's life I just don't buy it
okay the problem with me too is that it
was always fake news that's not not to
say that there weren't real things that
happened not to say that women weren't
actually harassed and mostly by
left-wing Democrats in Hollywood but by
other people too it's not to say that
the individual episodes were not true
it's to say that the me2 movement itself
never cared about the truth how do we
know they never cared about the truth
because the slogan was believe all women
not believe the truth believe people
based on their sex rather than the
evidence there is a much more general
lesson here to come for
the demise of me - and the lesson is
when you allow your political
preferences to become your standard of
truth you become much dumber you look
much more foolish you end up with egg on
your face if you just follow the
evidence if you just try to discern the
truth you might not always be popular
you might not always get all the press
attention that the me2 movement and
Alyssa Milano have but in the long run
you will look a whole lot better than if
you are just throwing out hack
accusations at you and serious
accusations at your political opponents
without any evidence because that's just
how you want things to turn out
politically it's not just Alyssa Milano
it's not even just the me2 movement
there has been a lot of fake news going
around and major mainstream institutions
have been promoting it not because
there's evidence that it's true but
because it suits their narrative we will
get to that in just one second first
I've got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite you know how much I love
NetSuite so right now especially in the
current economic climate it is
especially important for a business to
be on top of its numbers what to
companies like ring hint and to Kovas
all have in common they all use NetSuite
to accelerate their growth successful
companies know that in order to grow
faster you must have the right tools if
you want to take your company from 2
million to 10 million or from 10 million
to hundreds of millions in revenue
NetSuite by Oracle gives you the tools
to turbocharge your growth with NetSuite
you get a full picture of your business
right you get to see finance inventory
HR customers and more it's everything
you need to grow all in one place I
really love these guys and right now
especially if you've got a little time
on your hands
schedule your free product tour you will
not regret it and you'll get your free
guides six ways to run a more profitable
business at NetSuite comm / Knowles can
or wles do it right now a lot of
businesses are gonna need to take off
very soon they're gonna need to explode
their growth go to NetSuite comm /
Knowles canna wles so a similar fake
news story
similar disregard for the truth there
was a story that ABC News put out just a
few days ago of a nurse in tears
quitting her job because she didn't get
the kind of equipment that she needed to
fight the corona virus the tweet from
CBS News said quote in tears a nurse
says she quit her job after she was
asked to work in a coronavirus ICU
without a face mask America is not
prepared and nurses are not being
protected CBS News put that out one of
the big networks Bernie Sanders tweets
out this video major politicians turns
out it's a total fraud here's the woman
I quit my job today I wanted to work and
I was assigned to a Kovac patient on an
ICU unit that has been converted to a
designated köppen unit now the nurses
are wearing masks not even surgical
masks in the hallways when they're
giving report to each other I have my
own m95 mask I told my manager I
understand we're short on supplies so
the moment that I saw this video go
around from CBS News mind you my first
thought was nope no don't think so I
don't maybe I've watched too much
reality TV but I know a good performance
from a bad performance that was a very
bad performance why else did I not
believe it because it didn't correspond
to the other reports that we were seeing
around the country that hospitals were
being stocked with these things that the
state and local governments were doing a
good job and the federal government was
doing a good job getting these masks the
idea that hospitals would allow their
nurses and doctors to just run around
not wearing any masks at all nobody in
their right mind would believe that
unless you your standard of justice is
to just follow your own political
preferences to their wildest most
hysterical ends so I knew that was a
bunch of BS from the beginning but you
know if you don't have evidence you
don't want to call BS on it just a few
days later the evidence comes out to
give you a little bit of context here is
some of that crying nurses other work on
social media every single person that
you'll come into contact with this
has no coronavirus and don't worry the
coronavirus only lasts for up to three
days on unclench surfaces you'll be fine
okay so my main takeaway from that is
nothing in particular about the content
it is just that perhaps this lady does
not have everything put together and
then we find out she posted on social
media just a few days before she sent
out her crying video that CBS picked up
that she she wrote that she had anxiety
and bipolar depression that she hadn't
been working in the hospital for over a
year and didn't know she was ready to
return so now we have the new Jessie
Smollett and it might not even be her
fault she might have some serious
problems and CBS News and the fake news
media are just exploiting her and
sending her video around because it
suits their narrative even though their
narrative is completely fictitious just
like in the case of Jessie smell it the
people who pushed this will never pay a
price CBS News is not going to pay a
price here right many people are not
going to see the correction this is how
the fake news media thrive they put out
a completely fictitious story it gets
seen by millions of people then a few
days later when the truth finally
catches up with the lie they put out a
little correction on Twitter whoops
sorry out I guess we were wrong okay
never mind we'll clarify it's not maybe
there's some questions here you've
already had the millions of people see
the video you've already got the fake
story implanted in their brains and then
you know to a few tens of thousands of
people maybe see the correction some
don't even read it that carefully and
the fake news thrives even for the
people who do see the correction that's
fine that's fine because CBS News is
just going to wait for the next one
and pull another hoax and hopefully
they'll get away with it next time it's
not just CBS not just Alyssa Milano
check out the New York Times New York
Times runs an incredible story now on
the question of coronavirus medicine you
know there's this medicine home
hydroxychloroquine and it's this malaria
drug that has been shown extraordinarily
effective at treating coronavirus so
they're trying to ramp up production now
and you know treat the patients who have
this this pandemic because there's no
cure for it right it's a new corona
virus so we don't have a vaccine we
don't have a cure specifically for that
this is great news
we were told we can't reopen the economy
until we have some medicine to treat
corona virus well then we found this
medicine how great
remember the fake news media we're
telling us two million Americans or more
we're gonna die from this thing well I'm
sure glad we found this treatment that's
working incredibly well what could
possibly be wrong with that well the New
York Times figured out what's wrong with
them New York Times publishes this piece
by olga lucia
torres who teaches narrative medicine
that's her bio narrative medicine not
even gonna ask headline trump keeps
putting the lives of lupus patients at
risk the next line we now have to deal
with a shortage of hydroxychloroquine
the drug that's been keeping me alive
for more than two decades the guy just
can't do anything right can t they knock
him because millions of americans are
gonna die from this new pandemic that
nobody could have predicted trump
identifies a drug that works to treat
that virus and then they knock him for
using the drug because now other people
are not going to have the drug or
something maybe that it the New York
Times has decided that trumps saving
lives is actually killing people okay
here's just the first couple paragraphs
on March 19th I woke up made coffee took
my usual ten pills and turned on CNN
hoping to see Governor Andrew Cuomo I
got president Trump instead he was
talking about the drug
hydroxychloroquine as a potential
treatment for kovat 19 the drug he said
without providing any evidence showed
tremendous promise
Mike cheeks flushed with fear and rage
she says she's really upset that there's
medicine for the corona virus I'm
furious that people will get better now
she goes on quoting
I think it's gonna be great he went on
my life and that of millions of other
people who depend on hydroxychloroquine
to treat lupus changed in that brief
moment our lives were suddenly more at
risk Wow now I want to hone in on a line
here right in the first sentence she
said she was hoping to see Governor
Andrew Cuomo not Donald Trump because
Donald Trump was promoting
hydroxychloroquine and that was killing
people like her what she leaves out of
this this essay is that Andrew Cuomo
promoted the same drug he said the exact
same thing that Trump said but it's okay
when Andrew quote when Andrew Cuomo says
it it doesn't kill lupus patients but
when Donald Trump's is the exact same
thing for some reason that kills lupus
patients by the way hydroxychloroquine
we have a lot of it
there were no shortages of it being
reported it's apparently fairly
inexpensive to produce there was zero
evidence that anybody who relies on
hydroxychloroquine will die because of
some shortage because of the corona
virus this is completely made-up because
they've run out of the ability to attack
Donald Trump because Donald Trump is now
as identified and is promoting a
medicine to treat the pandemic that they
said was going to kill two million
people so then it goes on again never
mentioning Andrew Cuomo never mention
never mentioning any of the relevant
facts to this for now I will wake up
make coffee take my ten morning pills
turn on CNN hoping to see Governor Cuomo
not President Trump she doubles down on
it like somebody said somebody some
editor at the New York Times and maybe
should have sent her the clip of Cuomo
saying the exact same thing and pray to
God I don't get covet 19 and that I can
get my hydroxychloroquine filled my
daughter's smile is so beautiful I want
to continue seeing it
she teaches narrative medicine she does
not very good at writing narratives
herself I take it I mean good grief this
was turned in as a tenth grade essay
you'd have to give it low marks you'd
have to return it's a kind it's a little
weak guys the argument is weak the
writing is weak but it's saccharine and
sentimental the point of the argument
here
not to make an argument based on
evidence the point of it is to
emotionally manipulate people based on
lies being run in the pages of the New
York Times the New York Times by the way
a lot of good news coming out of New
York recently not that you would know
that if you read the gray lady in the
paper of record according to all of the
evidence available the curve is
flattening in New York that is to say it
looks like New York has light at the end
of the tunnel New York the epicenter of
coronavirus in the United States is
getting better in a National Bureau of
Economic Research working paper that was
posted on Friday the MIT economist
Jeffrey Harris shows that quote the
coronavirus epidemic curve is already
flattening in the city which is
surprising a lot of experts who expected
to see the numbers get much much worse
for the next two weeks before we came
out on the other side of it
this is what we had been told we had
been told now for a couple weeks
New York's not even close to the end
here it's not even close to the peak the
numbers are not even close to flattening
we're about to see hell for the next two
weeks and then maybe after that it'll
get a little bit better except right now
it looks like the numbers are already
flattening you don't need to just
believe this researcher in the NBER the
governor himself andrew Cuomo is
reporting the good news number of deaths
are up once again number of people we
lost number of New Yorkers four thousand
seven hundred and fifty-eight which is
up from 159 but which is effectively
flat for two days while none of this is
good news the flattening possible
flattening of the curve is better than
the increases that we have seen total
number of hospitalizations are down the
ICU admissions are down and the daily
intubations are down those are all good
signs and again would suggest a possible
flattening of the
curved so this is is all good news I
mean obviously it'd be better if nobody
were dying at all but relatively this is
very good news
remember how what was it two weeks ago
now president Trump said he was hoping
that America would begin to reopen that
things would begin to start looking good
around Easter well Easter is happening
this coming Sunday and it would appear
that even at the place that has been
most terribly struck by coronavirus in
the u.s. things are getting better
things are moving in that direction
you'll remember when Trump suggested
that Easter date all the experts told
him he was crazy we'd have to be locked
down for another at least another 3-4
weeks maybe another two months who knows
all the politicians we're gonna be
locked down not just through the end of
April we're gonna be locked down into
May we might be locked down into June
and so now we have this good news we
should be very happy for that good news
but we should raise our eyebrows that
the people and politicians who were
telling us that all the models showed
that we had to keep the global economy
shut down for another several weeks
because they're what they're gonna get
away with this is how they're gonna get
away with it they're gonna say right we
had these models showing terrible things
but then we all came together and we
social distance and we wore those masks
and so we were able to greatly reduce
the spread of the virus and reduce the
spread of deaths okay fine the trouble
is all your predictions were based on
people already doing those things it's
not as though the predictions of we need
to wait another three or four weeks or
two months or whatever it was based on
people going out and working and going
to bars and restaurants and going to
concerts the whole world was already
shut down all of the models were basing
their predictions on people staying at
home and social distancing and washing
their hands and wearing the masks so the
models were just wrong it would seem I'm
hoping the models were wrong everybody
should be hoping the models were wrong
then we've got to ask how did they get
it so wrong what are the political
incentives here because well we can all
celebrate that we're coming at the end
of this I think a certain group of
people are maybe not so happy to let all
of this government power go and that
would be the government officials the
bureaucrats and the politicians who are
abusing that
power during this pandemic and if you
want some examples of that look no
further than New York we'll get to that
in a second first I've got to thank our
friends over at you I got to thank you
you know we're all kind of locked down
and can't do very much right now
so we've been very happy to start this
new show all access live we're gonna
continue doing that at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific
tonight we call it a show it's not even
really a show it's just a way to hang
out we turn the webcam on sometimes
we'll pull out a musical instrument
sometimes we'll read Italian poetry
sometimes we'll have a couple adult
beverages you know a coca-cola here and
there and see how the night goes
so please join us we really enjoy doing
it and now we're our only social
interactions are over zoom and Skype
it's a great way to talk to all of our
listeners so check it out all acts is
live of RIT daily wire.com that show was
initially just for all access members
but we just added with this quarantine
we're gonna open it up to all of our
members if you're not a member go to
Daley wire.com slash subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
so after this research came out of MIT
that New York might be coming around
that the hospitalizations and everything
are remaining basically flat after
Governor Cuomo mentioned this the stock
market surged so people are very excited
on this good news a12 stocks rose at the
new york stock exchange yesterday for
every decliner for every stock that fell
the market rallied on the hopes that the
the new coronavirus is going away
overall 2700 New York Stock Exchange
listed stocks traded higher after the
news came out while only 231 fell so
great stuff especially now that we've
got it was 10 million people thrown out
of their jobs within two weeks we're
gonna get more numbers at the end of
this week I imagine those numbers are
going to be absolutely brutal because
the numbers lagged by a week so even if
things are turning around now the
numbers we're gonna hear this week are
gonna be the ones that are reflecting
last week's situation so we need to try
to pull out of this global shut down as
soon as humanly possible and yet for
some reason something tells me that
politicians are not going to give up all
the power that they just took they just
took a lot of power
they've just habituated us to a new
normal that's pretty eerie you want to
see how eerie it is yesterday in in New
York City walking right along the East
River
you see you see some pedestrians just
going out getting some air walking their
dogs and you can hear a sound in the
background and it's to stay in your
homes go back social distance sounds
like a police loudspeaker it's not
coming from a cop on a bullhorn it's not
coming from a car it's just coming from
a little drone that's floating overhead
and monitoring all the people safe
distance hovering over the water and
yelling at them to go back home
[Music]
the volunteer drone task force it makes
me feel a little bit better to see that
it's at least probably not a government
drone I hope it's not maybe it is maybe
it isn't
they say it's a volunteer drone if it is
and if New York were a civilized City
someone would have pulled out a 12-gauge
shotgun and blown that thing out of the
sky that is just a little too Orwellian
for my tastes okay little too
totalitarian for my liking to have a
drone flying overhead telling me what to
do and that is the future that some
people in this country want us to have
we got to start scaling back now the
government and the experts and the
self-appointed benevolent betters who
fly their drones over our heads are
drunk with power and the good intentions
that some of them might have in
preventing the spread of the virus or no
excuse for them to take that power the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and their models have shown
to be bunk we have to take back this
power that is not a situation that any
of us should be willing to tolerate now
there is some good news on the
pop-culture front because I just keep
asking myself if people become so
habituated to this kind of thing that
now they don't even care they're just
willing to let all this power go away
that's fine yep yell at me from a drone
tell me to stay in my apartment I'll
just I'll just work all day long in my
apartment not be able to go outside not
be able to do anything that that is a
fear because I think people have become
much more accustomed to giving up their
independence but on the pop-culture
front Joe Rogan is giving me hope Joe
Rogan kind of interesting political
views you know is he on the right is he
on the left he's kind of an independent
thinker he was a Bernie bro so you
assume Bernie's not going to win the
nomination now
unless Joe Biden for whatever reason
just physically can't make it over the
finish line so you expect Joe Rogan to
endorse Joe Biden but that's not what's
happening Joe Rogan was sitting down on
his show and was talking about who he
might endorse he said he would now that
Bernie's out he would rather vote for
Donald Trump than Joe Biden this is the
real issue with the Democratic Party
they've essentially made us all morons
yeah with this Joe Biden thing you
really have morons who do we need I mean
I know vote for that guy I can't vote
for him I can't vote for him I can't
vote for Trump there I'd rather vote for
Trump than him I don't think he could
handle anything I mean you're relying
entirely on his cabinet like we want to
talk about a an individual leader that
can communicate he can't do that and we
don't even know what the [ __ ] he's gonna
be like after a year in office the
pressure of being the president United
States is something that no one has ever
prepared for great the only one who
seems to be fine with it is Trump
oddly enough I mean he hasn't seemed to
be aging at all or any sort of decline
pretty astute observation we see that in
Trump's press conferences we'll get to
the updates from yesterday's press
conference in just a moment but it's
true you know Joe Biden we've seen him
for 50 years in public life he was the
vice president of the United States and
the last administration and even in just
the past few years since he left
government Joe Biden's decline has been
pretty precipitous and frankly even
while he was serving in the Obama
administration he was declining from
what he had been 10 or 20 years prior to
that he doesn't seem to be doing very
well and he's never had the big job he's
never had the actual pressure of the
presidency on him Vice Presidency in
many ways is sort of a cushy job being a
senator in many ways it's kind of a
cushy job could you imagine Joe bright
Biden in the pressure cooker of the Oval
Office sitting behind the resolute desk
he can't even sit behind his own desk in
his living room right now without
fumbling his words and forgetting where
he is so Joe Rogan is recognizing this
and he said you know I'd vote for Trump
over him not even because I agree with
Trump on policy matters but just because
Trump at least seen
to be with it at least seems to have
energy he can handle himself in a crisis
I think a lot of people feel this way
and the conventional wisdom is that this
pandemic is has all but destroyed Donald
Trump's chances of being elected
president if the economy remains in the
gutter that might be true but if there
can be any sort of modest economic
recovery from a far worse economic
collapse than we saw in the 2007
financial crisis from an economic
collapse that we haven't seen since the
Great Depression
there's any kind of recovery I think
I'll get credit for it I think that's
why he's going and doing these these
daily press briefings every day I think
that's why CNN is now often refusing to
cover him in his press briefings is
because they realize he looks good he
looks like a leader he's communicating
directly to the American people in a way
that we have not seen from our president
since Ronald Reagan and people recognize
this is a tough situation and he's doing
a pretty good job
I don't think Joe Rogan is gonna be the
last Bernie bro to get behind Donald
Trump rather than behind Joe Biden and
let's just take a quick little look at
the update from the press briefing
because interestingly the theme of
yesterday's press briefing was the theme
of our show today these false narratives
getting absolutely smacked down I mean
we've seen separate from the coronavirus
we've seen the Alyssa Milano me2
narrative get struck down we've seen the
New York Times get struck down we've
seen CBS get struck down and Donald
Trump doesn't want to just let us have
all the fun so he's getting in on it too
he did it yesterday
nobody dismantles the fake news better
than Trump so Trump was asked a question
about the inspector general from Health
and Human Services this is government
bureaucrat who was criticizing President
Trump and this reporter wanted to know
about his reaction to the IG report
listen to how President Trump takes it
apart he goes for the reporter's
credibility first and exposes the
reporter doesn't have very much the
Inspector General for the Department of
Health and Human
is released report today a survey of
more than 300 hospitals across the
country and the number one complaint
from those hospitals were severe
shortages of testing supplies and long
wait time I mean did I have the word
Inspector General really it's wrong and
they'll talk to you about it it's wrong
it's well where did he come from the
inspector general what's his name
it came from the inspector what's just
merit I don't know his name
well I'm using it let me know okay can
you find me his name I'd appreciate it
but sir these are all I can tell you is
this and put up on the board
you're gonna ask give a nasty Admiral
but we are doing a week or longer to get
there we've done more testing and had
more results than any country anywhere
in the world they're doing an incredible
job now they're all calling us they want
our testing what are we doing how do you
do the five-minute test how do you do
the 15-minute test so give me the name
of the inspector general could politics
be entered into that go ahead please go
ahead there's the money line the money
line is could politics be entering into
it a president Trump is calling out this
reporter for two reasons one to show
that the reporters don't know what
they're talking about the reporters with
a very straight face they say oh the
inspector general came out and was
criticizing you and so what do you say
about the inspector general because tell
me more about this inspector general oh
no it's the inspector general yet do you
even know the inspector general's name
no well all we know is that the
inspector general is criticizing you
gazing okay so you don't know anything
about this story you're just forming a
narrative that is against me and so I'm
not going to entertain that and so he
exposes that the reporters don't even
know what they're talking about then it
shows that the reporters are hiding the
game and the left does this a lot okay I
remembered the first time I saw the
mainstream media do this was actually
wasn't about coronavirus it wasn't even
about contemporary politics it was about
Christopher Columbus they were hiding
the game they were trying to hide there
real intentions here behind a title they
weren't coming forth with information
that would shed some light on it but
with Christopher Columbus there was a in
2006 there was a big hubbub because
there was an uncovered document that
showed that Christopher Columbus was a
terrible no-good dirty rotten scoundrel
and all the headlines like I'm not
exaggerating I would say Columbus
actually was a murderer or a tyrant a
terrible man new document proves it and
the new document was this one account of
Columbus being a mean guy and a bad
governor and it was the document that
was used to kick him out of the
governorship of the Indies but I kept
looking I said who wrote the document
when it when there were so many
biographers of Columbus who wrote it I
couldn't find it anywhere in the news
reports and then I looked I finally was
able to uncover the document was written
by Francisco de Bobadilla Columbus's
chief political rival in the Indies
that is to say you'd be like it would be
like a reporter pointing out that Donald
Trump is the worst man that ever lived
on the face of the earth based on a
brand-new report that came out from
Hillary Clinton okay the fact that
Hillary Clinton is Trump's political
rival is very relevant information to
any kind of report on his character that
she writes right because it shows some
of her biases maybe it shows where she's
coming from the same thing is going on
here but they don't want to admit that
so reporters were asking about the AG
ABC's John Karl initially says that the
AG was appointed this past January to
which President Trump responded that he
would look into it
then Trump was later asked a later ask
question about this he asked when did
she start serving in government the
previous administration thank you for
telling me that see there's a typical
fake news deal you know I told you what
you would put your third your race
reporter and what you just said is a
disgrace okay you asked me you said sir
just got a portrait take a look at what
you said now I said when did they when
did this person how long in Governor
well it was appointed in the Obama
administration thank you very much John
thank you very much you will never make
it go ahead just absolutely devastating
because there it is actually this guy
Jon Karl had previously said that oh yes
this person was appointed just by your
administration which I guess is
technically true person was was
reappointed by the Trump administration
but initially she started working for
the Obama administration and Trump's
whole question here was could there
possibly be any political bias
maybe I just maybe I'm just throwing
things out there spaghetti at the wall
and initially they say no then it
finally comes out that it was true that
wasn't the only issue of fake news it
was the only narrative that fell apart
yesterday another one had to do with the
Paycheck protection program this is part
of this relief package to help small
businesses and people who are struggling
a reporter asks Trump the question with
the premise that the Paycheck protection
program which has been by all accounts
quite successful is a complete complete
flop the Paycheck protection program had
gotten off to a confusing start for
small Wells Fargo has stopped taking
applications Bank of America and not any
more than prioritize taking applications
from clients that were already thank you
for the leaders tremendous numbers of
applications and of course there may
have been they wanted to have a slightly
different application they wanted have a
little different information but Bank of
America has been a leader they had
number one in terms of applications
I wish you'd asked the question
differently why don't you say it's
gotten off to a tremendous start but
there are some little glitches which by
the way have been worked out there would
be so much nicer if you
do that but you're just incapable of
asking a question in a positive take of
the measures it's taken the measures see
Trump's got to do two things and every
one of these answers he's got to answer
the question and give out the relevant
fact and then he's got to show people
the tactics that the media are using to
spin their fake narratives okay that's
maybe more important than even answering
the question because we even people on
the right have been in thrall to the
mainstream media for so long we've just
been brainwashed by it
we've been hypnotized by the mainstream
media even though we can point time and
again I could go on for another two
hours today of examples that just
occurred yesterday in the mainstream
press to push dishonest narratives think
of the nurse who says she doesn't have
any masks CBS News very scary music very
sad music think about all of these
narratives that we just we don't even
pay attention to if you had to pay
attention to every single one you
wouldn't be able to get anything else
done during the day so President Trump
has these two difficult tasks to do he's
got to lead the country give out the
relevant information calm everybody's
fears and simultaneously expose the
hackery the dishonesty the cynicism the
falsehood that comes from our mainstream
press he's doing both of those pretty
well right now I mean I think that's why
we have the daily press briefings it's
up to us when we see this stuff to call
it out as well don't give them an inch
don't give them any leeway there are
very high stakes here these people are
trying to take a lot of power away from
you in many ways they've succeeded in
the next few weeks are going to be
crucial to make sure that they don't
keep that power indefinitely all right
that's our show we got more to get to
we'll do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Winooski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]